[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
i am thrilled
to have
my guest with me today paul conte md
paul is a graduate of stanford
university school of medicine he
completed his psychiatry training at
stanford and at harvard where he was
appointed chief resident and then served
on the medical faculty before moving to
portland and founding a clinic dr conti
specializes in complex assessment and
problem solving as well as both health
and performance optimization serving
patients and clients throughout the
united states and internationally
including the executive leadership of
large corporations his new book is
trauma the invisible epidemic subtitle
how trauma works and how we can heal
from it you can find him online at dr
paul conte c-o-n-t-i dot com and also at
pacificpremiergroup.com
paul so nice to see you my friend
thanks so much for having me it's great
to see you too i appreciate it
and
i have been
looking forward to this conversation in
my mind's eye for some time
because we've
known each other for a while we met
through our mutual friend peter tia
and
i saw a very early
manuscript of trauma the invisible
epidemic we were doing the math
beforehand before we pressed record
around two and a half
yep or so years ago
and
i was so thrilled
that you were putting your experiences
and your approaches into book form the
fact of the matter is most of the time
when i have
every friend acquaintance and their
cousin and grandma
telling me they're going to write a book
or asking if they should write a book i
spend most of my time dissuading people
from writing books a because i think
they'll be
just redundant or not a great value add
and then on top of that i really just
don't want to be forced to read them and
my feeling with you is very much the
opposite you're such
a deliberate thoughtful and skilled
practitioner thank you and
i also of course value you as a friend
but i've had a chance
and i'm not going to
disclose details necessarily
but
uh i've seen you really intervene and
quite likely save lives and i i can't
say that
for many people so it's a real
honor to have you on i've been looking
forward to doing this for a very long
time i have the highest opinion of you
thank you just to establish that up
front and
with all of that
let's
jump in and
i would love to hear also because my
memory needs refreshing but for people
listening how you ended up in psychiatry
yeah thank you and i want to thank you
for your support when i was really
figuring all this out and deciding i
really want to write a book and it's
such a leap to take that your support
and encouragement about how that would
be a worthwhile endeavor and could could
really make a difference was so helpful
to me two and a half years ago and and
before then too so i i'm so appreciative
of that and it's sort of part of my
circuitous route you know that um i had
no pre-medical classes uh in college and
i had a business career and and you know
at some point in time i realized that my
my what has unified my interests across
time was really about people so you know
i studied history and political science
and art and and i was very interested
but ultimately it was really in the
people right and and that's what you
know this was also fueling my interest
in business was the people i was
engaging with what were they like and
how did they have these thoughts that
got them to where they're at and and it
was that sort of unifying element that
led me to go back to medical school and
think okay i'm going to learn about
human biology and just learn something
about human beings and it was there that
i realized like oh you can take this
medical knowledge right and and you can
take the sort of life knowledge right of
whether it's history or politics or
sociology just knowledge about human
beings right and you can you can put
that together with an individual person
right who's sitting in front of you and
talking about them
the specifics of their life and their
experience and you can put all that
together and and really be helpful to
people like really make a a concrete
difference that you can see that there's
a change and and that was
ultimately so appealing to me and i felt
like i could get that through psychiatry
and i think i found that to be the case
i'm so grateful for the vagaries and the
idiosyncrasies that ultimately led me to
be able to see all of this and choose it
as a career
have many follow-up questions but we're
going to
we're going to kind of flash forward to
current day and then we're going to
flash
backwards so i want to read
a little snippet
from the forward
in your book
and i think you'll recognize this and
then i'm going to ask you to add context
okay
why didn't you bring me a real doctor i
asked the nurse paul replied by saying
i'm an italian from new jersey
and that's when i decided i was willing
to talk to him my dad is an italian from
new jersey so i figured i at least knew
what i was dealing with
whose words are these
those were the words of stephanie
germanotta who's also lady gaga uh on
our our
first meeting i think what i would
describe is i think our our auspicious
first meeting
so
so she wrote
the
forward
uh to trauma the invisible epidemic
of course
you didn't start off
with clientele or clients patients
like her
could you tell us a bit about
since we've mentioned the title a number
of times
uh your own personal history
with trauma if you'd be be open to
sharing
sure
you know in the first part of my life is
up until around early 20s um i didn't
have major trauma in my life
and
in some ways i was fortunate to get
through the big developmental milestones
without major trauma and and it gave me
a sort of view of life that was then
deeply challenged by
a sequence of traumas that sort of came
in the second
part of my life
and
seeing how they made me
feel differently about things because i
had the sort of foundation of confidence
right in myself and also in the
predictability of the world that if i'm
engaging and doing the right things that
good things are going to come back to me
right and and how differently
i felt you know one after my brother's
suicide which was the the first of a
series of of of of quite traumatic
things that unfolded over a number of
years
the challenge of that of realizing that
i'm trying to figure out my way through
this and like how to go on with life and
how to support my parents right and the
people around me
while i have an awareness that like i am
different
right that now i'm i'm seeing the world
differently and all of a sudden i you
know maybe i feel a little bit like like
am i cursed is my family cursed is is
anything going to be okay
maybe bad things always happen right and
and it was it was once so i was so off
balance right and and in a way kind of
impacted impaired even by all of this
and realizing that but can i even trust
how i'm thinking because i'm thinking
differently and then i'm trying to use
the brain that's thinking differently to
figure out what's different and and
there was something quite scary
about that that i could also then i
could see when i became a psychiatrist
play out in the people i was trying to
guide or advise or take care of that
they also often had thought differently
about themselves they stopped seeing
that they could make their way in the
world or that they had good things to
offer or that they could even stay safe
and and that for me like really caught
my attention that hey there's something
going on here that is
that's very deep and also very insidious
thank you for sharing uh
and i just want to
echo
uh some of what you're saying
in my own personal experience with
depressive episodes which i've
had as a a mainstay of sorts
for most of my life and it's
it's it's it can be very terrifying and
certainly disorienting
say in the middle of a depressive
episode
to be aware
that you are looking at the world
through a distorted lens but to
have no confidence that you can correct
that lens it can be very
terrifying because you feel like you're
the prism through which you're looking
at reality is broken and you're aware
there's a problem but you can't look
through that broken prism to fix the
broken prism or or so you might believe
and it can be
extremely
disorienting and sometimes destabilizing
for sure right and i wanted to ask if
you might be willing to speak to some of
the other traumatic events and to
to place
us in time
starting with perhaps your brother
how old were you when your brother
committed suicide
so i was 25 at the time 25 years old
and
uh
are you willing if you are
willing to share would you be open to
mentioning some of the other things that
happened to you and the reason i'm
asking about this is not to
sort of inflict pain in revisiting these
things
but rather to share your personal
experiences because there are very
likely going to be people listening who
will identify with different parts
of your story
sure no i i understand and i think it is
helpful the context is is helpful and i
think it does it speaks to the impact of
repeated traumas right that not long
after my brother's death one of my best
friends a person i grew up with uh
died i died very unexpectedly you know
we were in our mid 20s
[Music]
several years down the road my
wife was injured and injured quite
seriously i lost another very close
friend in
under very tragic circumstances a couple
years after that
um
there were other traumas
that were interspersed that weren't at
that level so there was a there's a
sense of like continued negative things
happening my mother
became ill with pancreatic cancer
and died not that long after her
diagnosis and um and that was
very painful for for very many reasons
including the feeling that my brother's
suicide and the impact upon the family
had maybe predisposed her right to
getting sick which you know there may be
some truth to that there may not we
can't know the answer but but that
oppressive feeling of of like there's
one bad thing after another and i can't
control any of it and and amidst it if
i'm not
really grasping to
get to keeping a hold on my sense of
self that i could potentially lose that
too or a sense of my place in the world
right the idea you described of say what
amounts to learned helplessness right
that says i you know absolutely i see
these bad things i see what they're
doing to me but i don't think i can
change any of it that i could there was
a real danger
of that you know throughout that whole
period of time
and if we focus on
this term we've used now a number of
times trauma
how do you suggest people
think about or define
this term and i'll probably do this
quite a bit in our conversation just to
ensure that everyone understands the way
in which we're using certain
terms
but
how how would you suggest people think
of
think about trauma and if there are
subsets or different types of trauma
perhaps what those are
sure
i would describe trauma as anything that
causes us
emotional or physical pain that
surpasses our coping mechanisms that
makes us feel then overwhelmed often
overwhelms our nervous system right both
body and mind and then really leaves a
mark on us as we
move forward
and and trauma can be acute right a
single traumatic event an assault a car
accident um an injury in combat right
these trauma can be acute it can also be
chronic so the the chronic impact of say
ongoing abuse or ongoing neglect or even
ongoing marginalization right and we see
so much of this has come to the
forefront whether that's gender identity
or it's it's racial right how how many
people are
trying to exist and doing their best to
not just to thrive but doing their best
to survive amidst circumstances that are
constantly telling them that they're
less than or that they're at
special risk right that that's chronic
trauma and vicarious trauma comes from
really this wonderful fact that we can
we can be empathic and empathically
attuned to other people and we can feel
what they're feeling i mean that's a
wonderful thing that we can do that for
one another but it also makes us so
susceptible to other people's suffering
and pain and we can lose the boundaries
of what is us and what is them i mean
i'm not the only
physician to to say that that that at
times especially in the intensity of the
training period would have to really
stop and say okay wait a second what is
happening now is happening to someone
else not to me
because if i don't maintain that
boundary i'm too overwhelmed to help
them right but but if one is
empathically attuned which many many
people are
then then we don't bound ourselves from
other people's suffering so there's
acute trauma chronic trauma and
vicarious trauma and of course an
overlap there can be an overlap between
them too
i'd like to
you know since we're also you and i
catching up ourselves as friends not
just doing an interview
i'd like to share
an experience maybe in the last
category and you know i don't want to
it's not i don't wanna give it a capital
t
uh but
uh i've had a new experience and i've
never
passed through this type of shift in
myself i don't think
an acquaintance i don't want to say
friend but someone i know
had a horrible family tragedy not long
ago his teenage daughter was killed in a
head-on collision with a uh a large
truck like a mack truck
and
for reasons that i don't think what were
necessarily determined her car just
just swerved ever so slightly into the
incoming lane and
dead dead on impact and since that news
and i i get exposed to tragedies
every day i mean if you look at the news
you buy the newspaper i mean they're
tragedies everywhere so i don't know why
this had such a
disproportionate i don't say
disproportionate but such a large impact
when i'm exposed to tragedy of other
types all day long
but i have had
extreme anxiety
while driving almost every day since
that happened
right i could understand that yeah and i
don't want to take
necessarily
an anxiolytic just to mute the anxiety
or to suppress the symptom
but in a in a case like this just
because perhaps it's
maybe easier to tackle than something
like the childhood abuse that i
experienced
when i was really young
yes how might someone approach this or
the with or without professional
help and maybe this isn't
the forum in which to discuss it but i'd
love to hear any
thoughts you might have because i've
i've never experienced anything like
this before
actually tim i think it's a great
forum for it because it it speaks to
a common problem right and a general
principle in in approaching the problem
we have to divert our attention
from
our instability
at the unpredictability right of the
world around us like on some level like
we know that kind of anything could
happen right and and we're not safe from
moment to moment from tragedy right but
we have to sort of set that aside where
it's kind of in the periphery of our
mind and that's what lets us be able to
go on and like live our lives right
right and and things will happen
sometimes that really resonate with a
person now here it may be that something
makes you really identify with with this
person even though they're in an
acquaintance and say not one of your
closest friends right or it just may be
that something about the story or even
something about your own condition right
the fertile ground inside your mind when
you hear the story right
that makes it resonates with you and
then in this like that's a very classic
aspect of vicarious trauma then then it
resonates and you feel as if like that's
happened you get some shadowing of like
what that must feel like for that person
right and then it shakes your sense of
stability and predictability and its
ability to control the world around you
and be safe yeah and that starts making
you feel insecure vulnerable right like
it's a natural response
and the thing to do about it is to
validate it right so that's that's why
the primary point i would say in
response is to validate it because what
people most often do is the opposite
it's unpleasant
it's it it feels so bad that the person
wants to say there's something wrong
with me why am i feeling this way about
about this like it didn't happen to me
this is one of my someone in my close
family like is and we try and
try and to somehow invalidate right what
you're experiencing instead of saying
no it's understandable this is reminding
you of something that you do actually
know is true
but but it's bringing it to the
forefront of your consciousness the
vulnerability the unpredictability
difficulty controlling the world and if
we validate that and realize okay i'm
not learning anything new from this but
i'm feeling something very strongly
right and i want to honor that i'm
feeling that and then to be able to put
words to it with with someone you know
that you know and trust and to to be
able to say that helps to to pay down
some of the anxiety and distress that
often gets worse if the person is trying
to shove it down and invalidate what's
wrong with me that i'm feeling this way
right it just grows that tension
inside
yeah right that makes perfect sense to
me i mean you have sort of a catalyzing
event and then you have
so let's just call that one i i hesitate
to use this term like one problem and
then if you have a very self
defeating but but self-critical
judgmental response to it now you have
another
now you have quite another problem
and as as i'm thinking about this i
haven't i haven't really spoken to
anyone about this
but
i recall at the time
because you you have me wondering like
why did i respond to this in this way
and i think that uh the circumstances
temporarily right the circumstances at
the time had a lot to do with it i think
a number of very difficult unexpected
things had happened in my life i see
yeah i then also got the news
in a
somewhat
i don't want to say frantic but um very
urgent text from a mutual friend of this
acquaintance
and when i called there was some type of
help that i was
potentially being asked to provide and i
couldn't provide it and so i see i found
it very jarring in that respect yes so i
wanted to share that as an opportunity
for discussion if i could say back to
him that's that that makes me think
about the the sense of vulnerability and
in the sense of of like on i can't even
do anything to help right i mean there's
such a sense of vulnerability that then
gets reinforced by that and often people
do
want to help even when like there is
nothing someone can do to help right and
then the person feels bad they can't
make anything better make the person
feel better and that adds to that sense
of of terror really right and if we if
we sort of validate within ourselves i'm
doing what i can do like i can be here
for this person i can listen i can i can
let them
cry or be upset around me like that is
what there is to do
then then that can take away from the
from the sense of of desperation and
vulnerability and i want to help but i
can't because that critical voice that
you referenced is very very common in in
people who are conscientious which is
you know most people are conscientious
people capable of feeling someone else's
pain so that critical voice
that it comes to the force so readily
it's reflexive right which is where the
shame comes from and there's a whole
cascade of as you said secondary
problems
right to the initial negative thing or
the initial problem
uh thank you for listening and for
uh
talking through it okay
how would you describe
the current state of
treating
successfully
or unsuccessfully or anywhere in between
trauma what is what is the the sort of
current standard of care
and and what do you make of of some of
the tools in the toolkit
i i think the the short answer to the
question is by and large abysmal
yeah
and i think that's not because
know the people in the helping roles
like don't want to do their jobs or are
capable of doing their jobs but we've
evolved a system
that
that purveys mental health care
largely without attention to the actual
human being
right and this is a huge
problem right if you think about the
shortening of visits i mean how much can
you really talk about even who you are
or what's going on in you in in the kind
of brief often rushed and infrequent
appointments that we have in our health
system and an over-reliance on medicines
right which which leads to a paradigm
that just wants to basically take a
symptom inventory right say well tell me
an inventory of your symptoms and i used
to say this sometimes when i was
teaching where i would give an inventory
of symptoms of of a person who had a
rock in their shoe right and then often
at the other end of that would be like
what do you think is going on and and
people would have to say attention
deficit disorder right because you know
the person's not paying attention to
things they're distractible right but
but it if we just take symptoms like we
will get it wrong yeah absolutely we'll
get it wrong a lot and getting it wrong
is it benign it's just it's not that oh
no help is given because it because we
got it wrong no it's actually that harm
is done and the symptom inventory you
know make a diagnosis or several
diagnoses and then throw
by and large medicines at the diagnosis
just doesn't work and what we end up
doing is like so much in the american
health care system we spend so much
right but we are at the bottom in terms
of
industrialized countries of of outcomes
right and that's because we waste so
many resources by not looking in depth
at the actual problems and i think we
we do a very poor job at identifying and
processing trauma for for all of those
reasons
are there any places
this could be a country a city it could
be specific clinics that stand out to
you
as being on the
opposite end of the spectrum
sure either
highly effective or at the very least
more effective
with addressing trauma you know i have
some
information and data about what's going
on in in some of the european countries
but not enough to comment really with
any authority
i think that most of what goes on in
america ends up being
a very low bar right in a very formulaic
province of care
there are exceptions so for example the
bridge to recovery which is a place that
peter has talked about and i think is is
a place that really sets an example of
of of how to be different and of course
it's a residential facility right and
not everyone needs to or can go to a
residential facility but that route of
approach of really understanding the
people right and and understanding
developmental trauma even if the the
reason the person is coming to care
isn't specifically the developmental
trauma but realizing that people are are
we're all a whole right we're a whole
person with our feelings memories right
that evolve in us over time and and so
they do a wonderful job of looking at
the whole person they're not certainly
not the only entity that does that
including
individual practitioners right but by
and large it is it's hard to find
systems that that will treat trauma from
a holistic perspective
how do you find the
proverbial
or metaphorical
rock in the shoe
and by and by that i i know you were
giving an
illustration of a of an exercise when
teaching but
beyond
symptom inventory
how do you begin to unearth
the
causes
at play
with someone
what i find so interesting about this is
it's actually not that hard
if you can build a rapport
with someone where they feel like okay
you're not looking to fault me
right and you're not looking to
stigmatize me right and you're actually
interested in me interested in what's
going on in me so you know i i wouldn't
say to everyone i'm an italian from new
jersey right but the thought of hey it's
not your opening salvo it's not my
consistent opening right but when
someone is is you know you could tell is
in pain and you're thinking look is
there is there a route in which we can
connect right and you know stephanie is
an italian from new york right there's a
similarity right that can then establish
a rapport
that can then lead
the person with whom i'm trying to
establish the rapport to to really feel
like i can talk to you right i can i can
talk period i can talk openly and and
it's it often leads to right where we
need to go right because people often
are aware of like what's going on inside
us and what triggers them what's going
on in that the tape that's playing in
their head all the time right how do
they feel badly about themselves what's
their internal dialogue about themselves
and when when you let people start
talking very often they'll talk about it
even if they never have before they
might have had treatment for depression
in 15 different settings never talked
about trauma i mean by the way i see
this a lot that's not just you know a
theoretical example because no one's
asked about it and been and been open to
it and that reinforces the idea of of
shame and stigma no one's even no one's
asking about this even though we're
ostensibly here to talk about my mental
health right that reinforces the
messaging of stigma and shame but if you
give people an open venue to talk it's
it's remarkable how it can come to the
fore be processed or validated or
challenged however may be it's just an
an openness to it which involves a
milieu that allows for that to happen
which is something other than very very
rush like okay we have 15 minutes let me
let me hear your symptom inventory so i
can write a prescription and then the
next person can come in like that's
never conducive to openness and sharing
but if we make environments that are
open to that
really good things happen
i would love to
ask a question that that might pop to
mind for listeners as well
and
as just a backdrop you know i've thought
a lot about trauma i'm not i wouldn't
consider myself a domain an expert but
i had
experiences of sexual abuse when i was
very small and cons you know consistent
regular abuse for several years from two
to four at a babysitter's house and
so i've thought and read
uh quite a bit related to trauma but i
think it's important to note and please
correct me if i'm not getting this right
but that you are not a hammer looking
for nails with
trauma in the sense that you
cover a very
broad spectrum
of
different conditions issues wants
questions with
with patients and
it seems to me that there is probably
a potentially damaging just like the
symptom inventory is is not
neutral necessarily it can result in in
very bad outcomes
right i've done some reading on
controversy related to say suppressed
memories right so i'm sure there are
therapists who actually do a lot of
damage by
trying to fit a narrative of trauma to
every patient that they have in some way
and so i'd love to just hear you comment
on
sort of the the good the bad and the
ugly within the
discipline let's just say or skill set
of of treating trauma
so the first thing i would say is you
know i never made a conscious decision
to say hey i'm going to be a trauma
person
right right i mean what i saw was
oh this is running through like
everything that i'm doing
and at the time i really first started
seeing it i added open general practice
and i was seeing what are the
commonalities across people that i'm
seeing right socioeconomic demographic
background you know diagnosis right what
what are the commonalities and of course
i saw how often substances were playing
into what was going on and i saw even
more strongly than that how often trauma
was playing into what was going on
whether that was depression or anxiety
or insomnia or even the evolution of
psychosis or the triggering of bipolar
episodes i mean there was just so so so
much that was keyed to
trauma and and that's what really
captivated my attention and then grew my
interest and my research and clinical
approaches to it so i i i think it's
it's there and it's it's quite pervasive
but it of course isn't the answer to
everything
right and and yes if if if you have the
hammer and you want to see all nails
then then that's what we see right and i
think we have to be very very careful
because
you know we often as as human beings we
develop sort of allegorical ways of
understanding things right and we can do
that consciously and also unconsciously
so the idea of recovered memories from
the from the perspective of oh that
person had no idea that that thing had
happened right and now they know that it
has happened is something we we just
must be skeptical about in a way that's
careful right i don't mean skeptical in
a way of trying to invalidate a person
but but being careful because if a story
that's not actually true
becomes that person's touchstone for
truth right that is not good for that
person and it can be it can be very
damaging for others who then may be
falsely accused of something for example
right most of the time
and i've been doing this for 20 years
and i would say the vast majority of
times when someone is now talking about
a memory that they haven't talked about
before it is not because they had did
not have that memory before
it's because it was writing in the sort
of boundary being above and below
consciousness and they know that that's
there but they don't let it into
consciousness or let alone put words to
it right and then there's a way in which
the memory or the experience the person
is talked about
fits with their internal world before it
came to the fore
right as opposed to it in a sense kind
of coming out of the blue which we just
need to be more careful about for the
sake of that person who may have had
that come out of the blue right because
maybe that's true but maybe that's not
and if it's not it's not helpful to them
and it's potentially risky to others if
that makes
sense and and i think the more that we
work against stigma okay you know i'm
saying this because i believe with all
my heart that it's true that your
willingness to talk about your own
trauma it is is so
powerful it's so powerfully helpful
because you're pushing against reflexive
stigma
right because trauma makes reflexive
shame and reflexive stigma and that's
what makes people go underground so to
speak with their trauma and and that's
where confusion comes in right misery
gets compounded confusion comes in
because people are alone with something
that's terrifying them and they're alone
over time and their own brains can
evolve in ways that maybe sometimes are
helpful but maybe sometimes are not
helpful right so the more that we work
against stigma and shame and say look
what is there that's happened to a
person that that person should not be
able to talk about with trusted others
rather whether that's trusted friends
and family or clergy or or
helping people in helping fields right
that a person should be able to talk
about what's going on inside of them
because it's it's burying those
unhealthy seeds so to speak that that
then
compounds you know compounds original
trauma into something that can end up
being far far worse with a whole cascade
of problems could be depression could be
substances could be self-harm could be
an eating disorder there's so much that
gets compounded when the original trauma
gets pushed outside of consciousness and
outside of communication
it brings to mind for me
something and i'm paraphrasing here that
someone named gabor mate
shared on the podcast quite a few years
ago
and again i'm not getting this word for
word but he spent a lot of time working
with
opiate addicts in british columbia and
elsewhere yes
and
he
is
fond of saying we shouldn't ask why the
addiction we should ask why the pain yes
and
certainly in my exposure to
addiction my best friend from childhood
died of a fentanyl overdose and
brother's best friend from childhood
you know died in a drunk driving
accident a lot of substance abuse
where i grew up on eastern long island
and my uncle actually recently died of
i'm not laughing because it's funny but
uh alcohol
induced uh cardiomyopathy his wife my
aunt died of percocet plus alcohol so
i've seen
a lot
of addiction and i
what gabor says really resonates
with me
yes and
i would love to
if you're open to exploring
some of the tools in the toolkit and i'm
not implying that
you have all of you utilize all these
modalities in your
clinic in your practice but for those
people out there who are wondering and
we're going to talk about the framework
of the book and how you
put it together and what people who
don't have access to
paul conte
might expect to learn and be able to
apply from the book but before we get
there
you know in the last handful of years
as you know i've been hoovering up
a lot as a as an enthusiastic amateur
and have found certain things
personally very helpful
like ifs
internal family systems i found very
helpful i've helped fund some studies
with
different formats of therapy like cbt
or
what is it dbt dialectical behavioral
therapy yes and then i'm hoping
i think i am in the i think i've already
funded or my foundation has funded a
study involving
these acronyms get really tricky after a
while uh co-joint or conjoint
something that is conjoined and similar
to cbt but okay
maybe but the the idea being that you
are
using in this case therapy
mdma assisted therapy for not just
the
s the individual who experienced trauma
and i think in this case it's veterans
but also the spouses yes so there are
all these different approaches people
may have heard of emdr which i don't
have much experience with but all of
these various tools in the toolkit
are there particular and this may not be
a good question but i'm curious i'll ask
are there particular
modalities
frameworks tools that you have found to
be particularly helpful in
working with individuals who have trauma
in their background
sure no i think it's a it's a great
question and
i mean there are many arrows in the
quiver
right and cbt is is an arrow in the
quiver dbt is an arrow in the quiver
medicines can be an arrow in the quiver
but where it all has to start
is is a search for truth right because
trauma changes our
our emotions about things right our
feelings and emotions about things it
then changes what how we think right and
what our memories mean so we need to
look at what is the person's narrative
about trauma if they're identifying that
there's trauma and if not what is the
narrative about self
right because in unless we we understand
that then it's like trying to solve a
problem so you're trying to solve a math
problem but you don't know what the
equation is right like we're not going
to pick the right tool we're not going
to get to the right place so because
there's so much reflexive shame and then
a cascade that comes after that right
and a lot of times that involves like a
decrease in role performance right where
now the person doesn't they're not
performing their role say as a parent or
as an employee or as a friend as well
right then the person begins to think of
themselves in a different way and the
first thing to get at is what is the
person's narrative so someone who may
present and say oh i've you know i was
really got physically hurt in my last
relationship
but you know
i mean this is always what happens or
it's never you know never
goes any differently right i mean you
have to you know instead of looking okay
let's look at the trauma from this thing
that happened to you in your last
relationship you have to look at why is
the person approaching
the whole question of relationships from
a place that says things won't be okay
for me right what are the lessons that
that person has learned that are not
actually true
right and you have to go back to why
when did the person start thinking of
that i mean people don't i mean i'm
saying it for effect right but people
don't pop out of the womb thinking no
one's going to treat me well i don't
deserve to be treated well right i
always get hurt in relationships like
where long did that conception
come into to play and how much does that
person also maybe feel they don't
deserve anything better where did that
come from right and if we go back and we
look at the the formation of a narrative
that then furthers and perpetuates
trauma then we can get at
changing it right but then you have to
get at what is the pain that the person
felt right you know the the emotions
involved you have to go to a place
that's emotional but if you go to that
place
the actual events the emotions the
change in conception of self or
conception of the world then you can
come through and say okay what tools
does it make sense for us to apply right
because there are the arrows in the
quiver that you noted and a lot more
the question is knowing hey when does
one make sense versus another and i try
and i write a lot about strategies
antidotes in the book right and and i i
think they're you know in a sense
they're good ideas but i think they're
good ideas but they're good ideas only
if they're applied in the right
situation to the right person so it goes
back again to understanding the person
what happened to them and how what is
their narrative of themselves and what
the world can or can't be for them
well let's uh get personal and i'll be
the one to get personal just as a way
of exploring this sure if you're if
you're open to it sure and it's hard
maybe it's impossible to say i feel x
because of y right i mean if it were a
scientific study it'd be very hard to
get to conclusive
results nonetheless there's certain
events in my life and abuse
abuse experiences and so on that i think
have
formed
my worldview or informed my world
i don't want to put it all on that
there's probably
uh there must be more to the story but
uh i'd love to talk about hyper
vigilance for a second sure so this this
is from your book
when people suffer from trauma however
their threat sensor becomes hyperactive
and hyper vigilant convincing them that
things are dangerous and wrong right now
constantly it's like a threat sensor
recognizes that it was unable to prevent
the initial trauma and now it's trying
to make up for it by being active and
loud all the time
this is how i feel yes a lot of the time
and i've approached it from different
angles i've used heart rate variability
training to kind of start from bottom up
in other words not starting with the
language and the concepts and the
stories but starting with physiology i
found that quite helpful with dr lea
lagos and i feel like i've made progress
here but
nonetheless
i do
feel like my threat sensors are turned
to high volume most of the time and yeah
so i have these
fundamental stories and
since i suppose our stories become
filtering mechanisms for what we notice
and remember yes i can i can point to
long laundry lists of
evidence that support what i'm about to
say
not saying they're true across the board
uh
by any stretch but okay
the world is fundamentally unsafe it's
unpredictable
you should not trust like people should
earn trust but start
at a baseline of being
distrusted or viewed with some suspicion
right and
these
these
positions that i've established for
myself
i recognize cause
a lot
of anxiety anger
stress that is unhelpful in my life
yes i recognize
i'm fully aware of this and i beat
myself up uh
with respect to my apparent inability to
reformat my hard drive
do you have any antidotes for hyper
vigilance do you have a way of thinking
about it or approaching it that we could
we could discuss
i come back to
the first step being to
assess and validate like think about the
things that you said there's fundamental
truth to some degree right i mean the
world is not an entirely safe place
right um we can't control everything so
it's sort of like too much of a good
thing right and that's what
hypervigilance is right because we're
not saying we should have no vigilance
right i mean there are threat sensors in
all of us that that are supposed to be
kind of firing in the background you're
a loud noise you pay attention right
it's supposed to be in the background
but recognizing that that probably what
has pushed say that vigilance sensor in
you right up to
to a much sort of a higher place on the
scale
is is the impact of trauma right which
which takes reasonable concepts and then
builds the whole story around the
extrapolation of the concept to some end
that is unhealthy and maladaptive right
so take your your driving example
you're prompted i think from or
predisposed say from prior trauma right
to to have something that kind of hits
home really increase the level of
tension and vulnerability inside right
so so
one way of looking at that is to to
validate and say look i do actually know
that it's not completely safe to drive
so i try and have a safe car and drive
carefully like i know all of that right
but because i hear an example of of
something really tragic that occurred
while driving
then that vigilance sensor wants to
build the whole story around that and
wants to say that's gonna happen to you
right the chances of that are happening
are so high right and now it starts
capturing your attention and it starts
reinforcing itself right and then if
you're thinking on top of that god
what's wrong with me that i keep
thinking that that calls attention to it
too right and further reinforces it but
by validating that hey i'm an empathic
person
that that heard about a terrible tragedy
and the circumstances of that tragedy
are going to resonate within me and and
make the hyper vigilance in me attached
to that i i know this i understand this
i can step back to say reality testing
of saying i do actually know that if
there's some danger to driving i do
actually take precautions right
me learning about this tragedy isn't
actually making me less safe and maybe
it has me reflect is my car as safe as i
want it to be is there actually
something i can take away from it right
and and if i can't let me feel
a sense of grief for this person's loss
and feel a sense of sadness right but
make a conscious boundary that that is
actually not about me or my risk in the
world
i didn't learn anything new and and i
certainly don't want to then be beating
up on myself because i'm what kind of
hyper vigilant from prior trauma and
empathically attuned yeah and that's a
place where another example could be
where medicines could be helpful and
again i'm not saying this because i
don't know enough of the specifics but
sometimes a little bit of medicine for a
short period of time can help push back
the extra attention and the extra
vigilance to the point where things can
then go back towards normal so so
there's so many psychotherapy and and
medication tactics that can be used but
it starts with what is the truth of this
what is it actually telling a person
what does it mean to them what's the
narrative about it and how do we ground
ourselves to the truth of it as opposed
to shame and self-recrimination even
feeling bad that you feel bad right
right
and just
for
clarity
the the medicines in this case say
prescription medications
could be used
to
reintroduce my psychology
and physiology to
a state of non-hyper vigilance so i can
sort of recalibrate and recognize it as
a possible state
and that is done without the intention
of
chronic administration or never-ending
administration it is it is given for a
short period of time right or
maybe it's short i don't know i guess
that's relative but that that often is
effective and you can go sort of say top
down from brain to body but you can also
go as you were saying a couple minutes
ago you can go bottom up from body to
brain right because tension in the brain
makes all sorts of problems in the body
and one one very strong example of that
is the impact of muscle tension so there
might be muscle tension for example
between the ribs and now the person
feels a little bit short of breath right
where there's muscle tension in the gi
system another person is having ibs
symptoms right or muscle tension in the
legs and now there's restless leg
symptoms we can go the other way of
looking at the body and ways of trying
to relax the body and decrease the
tension in the body because that
decreases the signaling that goes back
to the brain what we don't want is a
cycle where brain is tense sends those
signals to body body gets more tense
sends those signals to brain that gets
more tense and you can see we can be in
a vicious cycle there so you know we
have a mind-body connection whether
whether we choose to pay attention to it
or not it's still there and often if
we're not paying attention to it it's
not that that's neutral either but that
that can can be quite negative so
looking at the whole person where do you
hold your attention how do you
experience your tension how much in the
way of words do you need to put to this
how much in the way to physical
interventions should you be doing should
there be any medicines but again we're
looking at the person like that becomes
very specific to you
as it should be
right
well i would love to ask a question that
is specific to you and this might be a
bit of a left turn but i think it would
be
i'm personally very curious
if we could go
back to
your brother's suicide and i know it's
probably not the easiest thing to talk
about but
that is a
i mean it's it sounds like uh
it's hard for me to conceive of a of a
larger
event at least in the vicarious trauma
category
what are the things
that helped the most
in terms of
coming to terms with that or healing
from that
to the extent that you have
sure
i mean i'll start by saying
you know i had no mental health
education or experience at the time
so my initial responses like weren't
very healthy right i mean i felt like oh
it's my fault i should have known
right i should have been a better
brother right i was probably fairly
depressed myself and drinking too much
and all sorts of other things that that
i was still like going along with life
but feeling very oppressed
and and feeling oppressed not just
externally but inside right so so this
idea that trauma changes how we think
about ourselves and then we're trying to
recognize that it's like trying looking
in the mirror and saying is that me but
you don't really remember what you
looked like yesterday right
so that was very scary and and a lot of
the ways in which i handled it were not
helpful or healthy
so ultimately when i think how did i get
through that
it was
interconnections with other people were
absolutely indispensable that there were
people around me who cared about me who
were then reflecting back to me like no
you're a good person and a terrible
tragedy has happened to you
which is like very helpful because they
they could see me
because they they knew me and they knew
me before the tragedy it was me who
couldn't see me
and they were basically communicating
you know
this something awful has happened but
you're the same person you were before
and that's a capable person and a caring
person right and that was immensely
helpful to me and and some of that was
through friends and family and also i
went and got some psychotherapy which
people weren't really doing like where i
grew up you know people didn't go to
therapy right where did you grow up
outside of trenton new jersey
and it just wasn't in the culture so for
me going and getting therapy even was
like something do i feel embarrassed
about that is it do do you know do
healthy people ever do that is that just
for crazy people like that you know that
was that was how it was thought of so i
had to do something that i think did
have some bravery to it of saying like
hey let me be honest with myself is i'm
not doing okay and and i'm getting help
from people right and there are people
who care about me but there's
professional help too and i you know i
just found a therapist and she was very
very helpful
to me in that basic grounding way
so
the impact of others was so helpful
because otherwise i i think i probably
there's a good chance i would have never
seen myself the same way again
in in a way that could have just been
worse and worse and worse and that's
ultimately what led me to is this kind
of come to a full stop and and look at
how it was handling my life
and and like their silver linings i i do
believe if we work
hard enough towards them there can be
silver linings to anything
no matter how bad it is and a silver
lining was i looked at myself and i you
know i'd wanted to go to medical school
but i thought i'm too old why because i
was 25 right like that's not too old
right but i i thought it was or i
couldn't leave my job because i was
making a good income and and if i went
to medical school i'm not gonna i'm
gonna pay and you know all these things
were in my head and people were saying
to me you're too old you can't walk away
from your job and it's gonna cost there
were so many things that i realized that
don't matter i'm like look i have my
life and i'm i'm you know healthy enough
that i can go do what i want to do now
go do those things
right and it was actually quite helpful
to me and decided i'm gonna leave my job
and even though i haven't taken a single
pre-med course i'm gonna go apply and
you know it led me to to feel emboldened
but i had to get to a place where i
could see myself as a worthwhile and
capable person that's how i saw myself
before
his suicide but there was a whole period
of time when i didn't see myself that
way and it was really other people both
personally and professionally that were
sort of for me a bridge to a place i was
not going to be able to get on my own
and i think that's the case for many of
us and when people don't have access to
people who care about them people who
can help them
you know we unfortunately there's a lot
of secondary tragedies that come of that
because we're interconnected as human
beings and we are not
kind enough and helpful enough you know
i write about like compassion community
and humanity and these basic principles
that i think we should be following
because i don't think they're rocket
science i think they're simple yet we
don't follow them and then we're not
there for each other in ways that i
think we want to think that we are right
but we often we're not living that in
the world around us
thank you for sharing you're welcome and
you've turned into one hell of a bridge
yourself so thank you that means a lot
to me to hear yeah it's it's true it's
true i i would love to
hear you
uh because i i haven't seen the the
latest and greatest i saw
v1 i saw version one of the manuscript
and i mean
he saw my
i read it with great interest and and
gave you uh uh
probably more more feedback than uh
any reasonable person would want uh but
i needed it
i needed that feedback it was strong i'm
sure it's
it's grown and developed
what is the
format of the book could you lay out
the basic structure of the book
sure
you were very very helpful to me and and
the few people that i asked to look over
that original manuscript really guided
me in the same two ways which was
towards having more of a voice that is
like just a natural voice when i'm maybe
talking to someone and i can tend to
become a little too academic as opposed
to like look that's not how i want to be
right so i i'm trying to write in a way
or i've tried to write in a way that is
just it's plain and clear and and
thereby hopefully effective right and
and the other recommendations were about
incorporation of stories yeah the things
in my own life in my work which is part
of my life right that that that really
emphasize the concepts and and that's
what the book is is like it's it's
meant to be read by
anyone and everyone who has an interest
in the subject material and it's very
personalized about me and the examples
in the world around me that illustrate
the concepts and with that in mind there
are four parts to it so the first is
what is trauma and how does it work so
that's talking about you know the
definition of trauma and the facets of
of post-trauma syndromes and how they
impact people so the cascade of henchmen
of trauma right starting with shame and
and and the all the others that come
along with shame so that's with the
first part of the book the second part
is the big picture so that's the part
that's the sociology of trauma of
looking at look how is this happening in
the world around us which my goodness
has come to a fever pitch with the
pandemic and and just the spotlight on
systemic racism and racial injustice in
the world around us and also on this
erosion of faith in our socioeconomic
foundation can you work really hard and
get ahead
like how does that work now compared to
how it worked 50 years ago so that's the
the second part of it and
in the third part i am
that's where it's sort of called an
owner's manual for your brain right
where i'm trying to to really look at
how does this work in the brain
what's the difference between the logic
systems and the limbic or emotional
systems in our brain how do we find
meaning in our memories how do our
memories change when our limbic system
changes the emotion tied to memories how
does trauma cascade through mind and
body so that's the the third part of the
book and then the the fourth is like how
we can beat trauma because again i do
not want this to be esoteric in any way
shape or form like the idea is that this
is well grounded in the practical like
what can we do and change now which
means it has to be
there to be things that we can employ
and that we can employ individually and
in small groups of people and in larger
groups of people which brings us back to
some things that that well actually the
majority of it really comes down to like
simplicity and there's a common sense to
it that i'm advocating for in the fourth
part of the book but i'm trying to use
the whole book to get us to the place
where like these
doable practical things are are really
at the forefront of our minds and the
person reading the book can feel like
right i can do those things i can do
them now and i can advocate for them in
the world around me and that's what
really you know brings it the the idea
that we're gonna we're gonna have
knowledge and the knowledge is gonna
make change
are there any particular
stories in the book i'm sure there are
that we haven't
discussed
that have resonated with proofreaders
and those who have had a chance
to read it do any come to mind
so my favorite story my favorite part of
the book might be my favorite story ever
in my own life
which i
shared i don't know if you
remember it was a while ago but you you
really did like this and that made me
feel good i believe it because it's a
positive story like there are stories
that are about how people get to the
point where like really bad things have
happened right and that's part of us
understanding but there there are
stories about overcoming too and you
know my uncle rango who was such a a
dear beloved person in my life is
someone
whose early life didn't look like things
were going to go that well right he had
a sixth grade education and not a lot of
guidance and support and then was
drafted in the second world war and
experienced some horrible horrible
things
during the war but
through
those experiences developed a sense of
self that that said i am a conscientious
person i am a strong person i'm a person
who can do difficult things and who can
do difficult things for reasons
that are so
strong that they that one can't look
away
from them and a person who can do that
those things should not feel ashamed of
themselves right should feel a sense of
pride amidst the recognition of tragedy
and and even with the sixth grade
education and the limits that that kind
of of you know lack of exposure to the
bigger aspects of of the world and even
of how our minds work was able to really
understand that and have a very very
good life and part of why he had a good
life i think was the silver lining of
the trauma that he experienced in the
second world war because he came out of
it with a sense of self that said you
know what you're not a delinquent loser
right you're the opposite of that you're
someone who leads men to safety when
they're otherwise likely to be killed
who who does and i won't sort of give
away the story but does something
incredibly difficult that haunted him
his whole life because in his opinion
which i i think i don't understand what
else there could have been to do but
what he did because that was what was in
front of him and he didn't see it as his
fault in a sense that would have brought
him shame
if that makes sense and that's why i
think it's my favorite story and even
before when i was younger i was able to
put all this together i could see
reasons to feel that made me feel proud
and made me see hope in that even when i
was quite young
his story was very
empowering even though we didn't know
the details he never would tell us the
details but we knew what he had come
through and that he was this decorated
war hero and we felt proud of him
because he felt a sense of pride in
himself
that's right i do remember uncle rango
yeah how could one forget
could you speak
to
or define selective abstraction because
this this is something that might be
worth digging into sure
selective abstraction is when
we take one detail from a big picture
and we construct the story of that whole
big picture around the detail
an example
it's probably a common example but even
in my own life is like i can come to
work and i can have a good day at work
and feel like i'm doing good things and
i'm helping people i generally can feel
good about things but then if i can't
find my keys when i'm leaving and this
is like it's really happened and then
you know i'm frustrated now and i'm
frustrated with myself and when i
finally find my keys or i get people to
help me find my keys the narrative
that's going on in my head is like what
a loser right i mean you can't even find
your car keys to drive home what the
hell is wrong with you and like that's
the story and then i can get home and
like my wife could ask me how was your
day i'm like ah you know
it's a terrible day because i'm
incompetent right because like i built
the story of the whole day
around what the salient negative right
the thing that triggered in me
you know my own susceptibility to
thinking i'm not i'm not good enough and
what i'm doing isn't worthwhile enough i
know look what's wrong with me and
that's selective abstraction because
that was probably 10 minutes of my day
but my brain builds the whole story of
the day which is my story of myself
right around that negative thing
yeah it's uh
selective attention is a hell of a thing
right it's
it's like you buy that and you buy a new
car and all of a sudden everyone's
driving the same car but of course
those cars are already out there
you're just paying more attention now
and that's so big because this is all
about salience biases what are we paying
attention to right and trauma makes us
pay attention to the negative that's why
we think the world is less safe of a
place or that we're less competent
people like this is the danger that we
we use selective abstraction and
salience biases and attribution biases
where something negative happens then
i'm going to attribute it to me
and i see this all the time where you
know something negative may happen next
door a person had nothing to do with but
they feel that it's their fault because
we get enough of this in ourselves and
we we literally forget who we are
or what we're worth which is why people
will stay in jobs that they hate when
they could try something different or
they'll stay in abusive relationships
when they could end the abusive
relationship and not enter another one
right it's this this where does all that
end up it ends up in learned
helplessness and
learned helplessness pushes people
towards more trauma and very often
towards death
could you say more about that
when you say towards death
because the the accumulation of trauma
makes people more and more desperate for
ways of of coping it's like you know you
had made that you talked about drug
addiction and we talked about the
decrease in role performance and the
shame that comes along with it and the
stigma i mean nobody decides you know
i'm going to use drugs because what i
what i want to do is ruin my life no one
makes that decision right so if we look
at as you were saying
dr mattei was saying it's like look at
the pain in the person like
where did that come from and not always
but a lot of times where where drug
abuse and drug addiction comes from is
it comes from pain and suffering and a
desperation to feel different so more
pain and suffering means people are more
likely to repeat maladaptive patterns
that lead them to more trauma
and they're more likely to feel
desperate for soothing in a way that can
for example pave the way to substance
use because the imagine like a set of
blinders that it starts off they're
outside of our peripheral vision so
they're not affecting us at all but as
time goes on they can encroach more and
more and more as a person is more trauma
less healthy coping mechanisms a more
negative view of self a more negative
view of the world and then the blinders
come in and at some point the blinders
are so narrow that all the person sees
it could be is basically a helpless and
hopeless picture
right and that's where a lot of suicide
comes from yeah absolutely and where a
lot of accidental deaths come from so
often the goal
is when i think about what are we doing
in trauma treatment and the image that's
in my head a lot is i imagine a set of
blinders a person is just peeking
through with one eye and we're trying to
pull them out so they see the breadth of
truth right the breadth of their
perspective allows that person to again
see truth and remember oh like an
example you know i absolutely understood
at one point in time that violence is
not acceptable in my life
right i understood that and i don't
believe that any less now than i did
then
but boy i kind of forgot it in the
middle
because the person forgot that they
could have a life free of violence or
that they deserve a life free of
violence that's where this narrowing of
blinders and the change in emotion and
how emotion impacts our memories and
tells us what our memories mean
right the memory of something happy with
other people can go from being a memory
that says right i can do anything and i
can interact with people and they like
me and want me to be around to a memory
of something that's impossibly lost for
the person and again that's not true but
if you see it as impossibly lost
it is unless there's some process that
leads you to a place where you remember
what's true that you forgot
you know this brings to mind for me
one tool in the toolkit and it's it's
more of a category but it's it's one i
would love to hear your current thoughts
on
i do think
and i'll get to the punch line in a
second that
it's very dangerous to view anything as
a panacea or you know fix all of any
type and it's particularly common with
what i'm going to mention which is
psychedelics yes but as we're talking if
we for the time being
include mdma
in the category of of psychedelic just
to make it
a little easier to discuss even though
one could argue it doesn't cleanly fit
in that category right but as an in
pathogen it is remarkable to me
how
patients
say going through
the
maps
trials
phase three trials and so on can
re-contextualize
memories
that
for decades have had a fixed
emotional
tenor yes and suddenly they're able to
go back
and
with a decreased fear response
unwrap that memory recontextualize it as
an adult with better coping mechanisms
and sort of reinstall it so to speak yes
it's really
a fascinating replicable
phenomenon yes for a lot of patients how
do you think about if you do it all
psychedelics their use abuse roles
misapplications
where's your current thinking so my
understanding from
the research the really consistent
reports right it tell me that
there's something immensely powerful
here that has the capacity to do an
immense amount of good but we have to be
careful with anything that's even
moderately powerful let alone very
powerful and that we're figuring out how
to deploy
these kinds of tools to do something
amazing and and i say that in like the
full meaning of
that word right because what they seem
to be able to help people do
is to look at
trauma
right
from the perspective of truth without
the reflexive shame this is someone else
hurt me what's wrong with me
right why am i being hurt right like
that's the reflex and it generates shame
that imagine how our perspective is
already immediately altered right if
trauma arouses shame
then the trauma itself immediately
alters our perception mechanisms
that we can use to understand the trauma
and navigate our way through it and i
think that goes hand in hand with this
idea that you know we value so highly as
human beings the outer
parts of the cerebral cortex the parts
that are uniquely human the parts that
let us for example have a language
and and the five senses which i know i
understand they're not uniquely human
but these are the parts though of the
outer cortex of the brain our ability to
plan and to project into the future and
we value these so highly but we do that
in a reflexive way why do we value that
just because the end point of the cortex
is the farthest the brain is grown
outward right that's the part that is a
budding up against our skulls right but
like we don't do that with roads i don't
say that if a road is going somewhere i
want to go that oh but it's better to
keep going maybe that road dead ends in
a muddy place i can't get out i mean
what may be happening is that there's a
brain stem that's the earlier part of
the brain right the first part of the
brain it's about like the basics of
survival right temperature regulation
sex drive appetite right and then at the
other end of the spectrum there's the
cortex that is about the things that we
need in order to sort of keep us alive
and that may be like what the five
senses are about for example that this
is about like in a sense vigilance and
it's about keeping us alive and that's
important but it may be
that the brain stem
which is sort of about just staying
alive and the cortex which is about
staying alive in a different way by
monitoring and navigating our
environment are less interesting than
what is in between right so that's where
the amygdala is grand central station
for negative emotion and the emotion
that impacts vigilance the hippocampus
which is about memory what's the
hippocampus connected to the amygdala
right so the limbic system and emotion
is so important to what how we remember
things and the meaning we put in
memories and to the insular cortex a
part of the brain that it may be that
the insular cortex is really about life
lived or life felt and understood and
that these medicines along with
psychotherapeutic tactics can do this
too and judicious use of standard
medicines can help do this where we're
living more in the part of the brain
that can actually understand and assess
what life is about right and it may be
that the psychedelics altering the
default mode network and changing how
the brain is communicating where the
seat of the brain's existence
consciously and unconsciously is at
opens up the ability to get out of the
cortex and into the part of the brain
that says
gosh something terrible happened like
what is that and what does that mean
right without all the the reflexive
loading of guilt and shame the million
thoughts we may have had that can
perpetuate guilt and shame and a
narrowing of perspective yeah that's an
excellent way to put it it's almost as
though you know before we consciously
think about trauma for
many of the people who have
suffered trauma if not most there's
almost a boot-up sequence in the
background which is
what you're about to think about or talk
about was your fault because you're
flawed yes
and if that is the canvas upon which all
subsequent thoughts are painted right
you can predictably
experience
a very
challenging interpretation of yourself
and of of events the thing gets
reinforced right because that
challenging interpretation gets
reinforced the next time you think about
it and the next and the next and the
next yeah you talked about the default
mode network i mean this is this is
obviously a topic uh sometimes a
controversial topic of conversation
among the
neuroanatomists and researchers looking
at psychedelics there are a number of
aspects also that
as we're talking
are of of great interest and of course a
lot more research is needed to delve
deeper and even confirm
the
sort of therapeutic implications of what
i'm about to to say but right you know
one is
sort of bottom up which is neurogenesis
so if
if certain psychedelics like psilocybin
as found in philosophy mushrooms
or synthesized for that matter
has
neurogenerative effects
in places like
potentially the hippocampus and
elsewhere and at least anecdotally seems
to have some effect on tbi and veterans
for instance
you know is it plausible that any type
of
sort of neuronal and you you'd probably
be able to speak better to this than i
would but
more eloquently certainly any any sort
of chronic damage or atrophy or
maladaptation from a neuronal
perspective from chronic depression
also respond favorably sort of bottom up
by bathing in some of these compounds
for a period of time i i do think it's
quite likely that there's there's
something there
from a just a mechanistic
sort of neuronal perspective the the
other is that
as we're talking about this
this overlay of i as we talk about or
think about trauma right
when you have
hypothetically let's just say decrease
in activity in the default mode network
and uh certainly if you experience ego
dissolution in any capacity where the
the entire sort of skin encapsulated
concept of eye begins to
loosen its grip on your perception
if you then revisit trauma
if there is no eye or
less of an eye it becomes harder to
blame
yourself right if not impossible for
what you are witnessing so you have the
ability also
to become an observer
who is not just less prone to
self-judgment
this isn't always the case but in some
in some instances you are incapable of
self-judgment
and it's uh it's very peculiar but
certainly
in the reports out of say
sessions from johns hopkins and
elsewhere
it's
remarkable to see what these compounds
can do and it's very tempting
to view them as the holy grail
which will solve all of our
miseries and pains and i i think that um
that is
i feel like i'm talking too much but
just i'll finish in a second that that
it's it's very tempting with anything
new
to
overestimate
the
applications and some early studies can
also
seem to overstate the efficacy right and
this is seen in in medicine and
psychiatry over and over again
i wanted to ask you
that we can come back to this this topic
of course because
my listeners know i'm happy to talk for
hours about this but
i'm curious on the let's just call it
more conventional side and with with the
caveat that we are not
uh providing medical advice
uh i am certainly not a doctor i do not
play one on the internet but um
you know this is for informational
purposes only and it's a conversation
between you and i
in the case of say hyper vigilance
because within the
conventional
pharmacopoeia
uh you have i mean there there are
incredible drugs available and
you know western
medicine uh despite the tendency these
days for a lot of folks to who poo poo
western medicine i mean it is the
the most effective healing
system ever devised by humankind kind of
a full full stop yes so within that
massive
list of options and all the available
options
what are some of your preferred options
and feel free not to answer this if you
don't want to but
if we were looking at a case say of
hyper vigilance and you you wanted to
put someone on a short cycle
or i should say a a finite cycle of
a compound or compounds
what what are at the top of the list and
how do you go about
selecting for someone
the first thing to say is we have all
these arrows in the quiver
right and and the in pathogens are
potentially
these new
wonderful arrows in the quiver but we
need to understand that and there can be
a tendency to overestimate benefit and
underestimate risk so there's research
going on that says
these can be just fantastic tools in the
quiver we need to understand them better
right and as that research is coming
along what i believe we should also be
doing is looking at the arrows we
already have in the quiver that we are
not utilizing effectively definitely and
that includes all the psychotherapy
modalities that get under
utilized right because we're just taking
inventories of symptoms and trying to
treat a symptom and call it good the
same is true of medications that if
we're really paying attention to people
into what's going on in them we can then
actually target symptoms but we're
targeting symptoms and understanding
what the big picture is like right right
exactly there's an outcome beyond
suppression right or there's a target
there's an intention beyond just
alleviation of symptoms right so if you
told me that that now
after the the tragedy that you learned
of that you have an increased sense of
tension in you all the time then i would
look to for maybe an ssri kind of
medicine a medicine that could improve
your distress tolerance right because
that extra tension is in you all the
time
if you said no it's actually only only
in me when i'm driving and like i'm
getting a little tremulous and i'm
sweating we might think about another
medicine that can block the the impact
of that extra tension on you physically
because then that's reinforcing and then
you get into that mind body body mind
vicious cycle what class of of drug
would that be so like a beta blocker
for example right it would be a
possibility in that scenario or if you
told me like everything is okay but i'm
really having trouble getting to sleep
because i can't get this out of my mind
then i would not suggest a sleeping
medicine because i would think there's
nothing wrong with your sleeping system
but but sleep is being blocked because
your distress system
is is amped up and when that when your
brain's trying to sift down into a
peaceful place that's the time that the
intrusive thoughts about this new trauma
come into your mind so can we use
something that that in a time limited
way like right around bedtime decreases
the the
the distress signaling in your brain so
that you can fall asleep as opposed to
like a heavy-handed intervention
which would say let's put you on some
sleep medicines when it's not really
your sleep system that's broken it's
your distress that's higher that kind of
thing yeah just because i i love the the
details of this kind of thing what
class of of compound or drug might fit
that
last
example right the distress
signaling prior to bed yeah this is one
of the interventions and it may actually
be the intervention i got to think hard
about that that has the most success if
not it's in the top three which is using
medicines that are called antipsychotics
but that's a terrible name it's saying
just because terrible medicines are but
just because they're used for that
doesn't mean that's all that they do
right it's such a misnomer to name
something by like what its first use is
right i don't call it a dollar a
baseball card buyer even though that's
probably the first thing i bought with a
dollar right so it stigmatizes the
medicines and then they don't get used
for this but low dosing of those
medicines blocks what are called d2
receptors blocks receptors that are
around distress transmission and very
low dosing is often immensely helpful in
situations where there's a lot of
distress signaling and that's impacting
sleep so i can't count the number of
people i've seen who can't sleep and
they've tried quote unquote every
sleeping medicine and sometimes they
actually seemingly have right but but
they're not gonna sleep then because to
say oh they have a sleeping problem just
pointing out the obvious that they're
not sleeping that's not a medical
conclusion right but to point out their
sleeping system isn't broken hence no
impact from the 15 sleeping medicines
but but their distress signaling is now
increased because of some
new trauma or triggering of an old
trauma or vicarious trauma then we can
solve that often very readily and and
that leads back to you know you were
talking about the in pathogens and the
idea of neurogenesis and and it may be
that
neurogenesis is very helpful in certain
parts of the brain it may be that
neuronal pruning is helpful in other
ways too right that's a good point what
we're really trying to understand is
what positively impacts connectivity
and and that may be neurogenesis in
certain parts of the brain but it may be
changing balances of neurons and maybe
it's neurogenesis of inhibitory neurons
yeah so things get complicated enough
that like how we can look at that though
in a practical sense because we're not
like the core neuroscientists right how
we can look at that practically is
saying what we're trying to do is alter
brain connectivity whether we're using
psychotherapy or a hug to a person that
you care about or we're using medicines
or we're using western medicines or in
pathogens what we're trying to do is
change the the sequence and patterning
of brain connectivity from one that is
stereotyped in a negative way right the
use of that reflexive shame ones that
that primes the audience before the
curtain goes up to say the play is going
to be bad and you're going to hate it
right
so when we shift that we're really
shifting connectivity and that's how we
can see old things in new and true ways
what's so
wild also and these are just occurring
to me as we're talking what's so wild
about some of them pathogens and also
certainly
psychedelics many psychedelics
is the phenomenon of hypernesia
i mean where you will be able to recall
the
say in in my case for instance like the
brown corduroy
on
the couch when i was
two or three years old i mean and i and
immediately recognizing that that is a
real
that is a real memory i have photographs
you know i can go find them i just
hadn't seen them in deck decades yeah
and it's it's really remarkable and
it's so easy with neo-mania to focus on
even though many of these compounds are
have been used by humans for millennia
they are new in their popularity as it
exists today and it's easy to discard
things that could be
very very effective either as
monotherapies or perhaps even in tandem
although you have to be careful
obviously with combining things
when uh when we take a look at the
antipsychotics since that's not at least
categorically something i'm familiar
with what are some of the frontline
antipsychotics what are the na the the
compounds are the names i'm just
wondering if there are any i would
recognize
there are probably two dozen or so of
these kinds of medicines the ones that
are they're very very potent for actual
psychosis are in general not what we're
using there's some older medicines so
even chlorpromazine which is it's the
generic name of thorazine i was going to
say thorazine is probably the only one
that i'm familiar with right which has
been around that's the first one it's
been around for somewhere around 70
years now
and it's what's called a it's a low
potency medicine meaning that it doesn't
block those receptors very much
but but even a little bit of blockade
can make a a huge difference so a
medicine that was used in like 800
milligrams a thousand milligrams to
treat psychosis very often at 25
milligrams 12 and a half milligrams
maybe 50 milligrams can decrease the
distress signaling
enough that then rumination at bedtime
you know the distress that that causes
so much misery then can can go away so
it's the example i would cite because
in low dosing it's it's a overall again
everyone has to make their own medicine
decisions with the person prescribing to
them but it's overall a safe and low
side effect medicine at low dosing and
and often remarkably remarkably
effective so that would be the one that
i would really
highlight uh and i think then we're
decreasing the distress signaling which
creates stereotyping of our thoughts and
feelings right if we're thinking the
same thing over and over again then
think about how that would predispose to
blocking memory i mean if you think of
prior trauma and there's a reflex that
immediately feels shame and
responsibility you know my god how did
that happen how did i let that happen
like all those things we beat up on
ourselves how are we going to remember
details right it may be that the
connectivity changes in more peaceful
states of mind which could be through an
in pathogen or not again the research is
bearing that out lets a person know and
remember and understand more because
that's not blocked by like trying to
have calm thoughts in the midst of a
hurricane right you're more likely to
have calm thoughts in the midst of a
calm setting and as important as that is
outside of us it's got to be at least
equally important inside of us too
absolutely in what category does lithium
belong because i've also read quite a
lot about
i suppose there's a as a monotherapy for
something like and please fact check me
on something like like uh i want to say
i want to say bipolar but maybe i'm
getting this
right yeah we're looking at like 1500
milligrams or or something like that but
uh
i
i was sent some reading related to very
low dose and they're different uh
different types of lithium right there's
lithium carbonate lithium oreotate there
are many different forms but
of really low dose like five milligram
10 milligram
uh pre-bed and i'm wondering if that
plausibly would have any similar effects
or if it's
exerting its effects differently
i'm not familiar with how lithium works
the most helpful way to approach lithium
as being
two entirely different medicines
depending upon dosing yeah and maybe an
even better way to look at that is a
dosing
a medicinal dose versus a supplement
kind of dose right so lithium
in high dosing is a very effective
medicine for bipolar disorder
and there are a lot of medicine choices
now so we can kind of nuance that to try
and minimize side effect and get a very
effective medicine regimen with low side
effect but for a long period of time
there weren't a lot of other medicines
and then high dose lithium monotherapy
was what happened most of the time for
bipolar disorder
which can be is often very effective but
has a lot of side effects like that's
lithium as medicine
right and and that's also a reason
lithium often has a stigma
around it because it was used for
bipolar disorder in a way when we didn't
understand as much about it oftentimes
the illness was out of control by the
time it was treated which can happen now
but was more so the case then so that
led to lithium having a stigma around it
but
everyone has lithium in them to some
degree we all do as human beings there's
lithium in all of us right and what
seems to be the case and again it's hard
to do great studies about this because
it just looks so big to try and do but
what seems to be the case is that
more lithium including more lithium in
the ground water so small amounts of
lithium but that are lithium that are
higher in all of us
seem to sort of make everything better
right it seems like there's less
depression there's less violence
there may be less dementia and one could
think of putative mechanisms like if you
think through you know how lithium
impacts ion channels and neurons in the
brain we can think of how that might
make sense but we don't know that for
sure but but what we do see and i've
seen just over and over and over again
is that in the right person and again
you have to be guided towards it because
there could be side effects from it it
can negatively interact with other
medical conditions so so if a person is
getting the medical guidance to safely
take low-dose lithium that that often in
a way that really is looking at it like
a supplement can often be very helpful
to the person including an increased
sense of calm an increased sense of
peace so for mild problems around sleep
a little bit of lithium can be very
helpful for bigger problems once a
person is getting ruminative and really
can't sleep and you know the cat's out
of the bag and it's going over and over
and over again then usually we're beyond
we are then beyond where a supplement of
lithium is is likely to be helpful
yeah lithium is fascinating to me i
agree call at some point
being sent a piece it's an older piece
i believe it was in the new york times
and the headline was something like
maybe we just all need a little bit more
lithium now understanding the
limitations of observational studies or
what you can do by torturing the data i
mean i understand the the shortcomings
when something isn't isn't controlled
and
possible controlled and randomized and
so on nonetheless i i recall this piece
pointing to
groundwater levels of lithium yes and
there being an inverse correlation of
hospital admittance related to you know
homicide suicide psychosis etc and
at the very least i found it very
thought provoking
how would you think about
for instance and i know this is a little
bit of inside baseball but i i am so
endlessly fascinated by all of this
and i i've heard very mixed things but
trazadone is a sleep aid yeah maybe you
could speak explain what that is my
understanding is that it is an ssri but
that it was never effective as an
antidepressant because people just fall
asleep
and therefore
like many drugs in our pantheon
uh
was sort of repurposed
for
sleep i don't know if that's accurate
but could you
i'd love to hear your opinion sure first
thing i should say in the in the
interest of full disclosure i think i'm
the person who sent that the lithium
article
in the new york times you know what
because you might have sent it to me or
you might have sent it to peter in the
community
right
of course of course right so i want to
say whoever sent that article was
brilliant and precious but no it needs
to full disclosure i think it was me
because i do believe in that i mean as
you said it's very hard to do these
population studies but there is some
good data that that points us in the
direction of all that being true and to
the very low risk of low-dose lithium so
then you you have a higher likelihood of
a benefit you know like high likelihood
of some benefit with low risk right that
being said that the trasitone question
specifically so trazadone
was found to be so sedating for most
people and and it seems like they're
probably some genetic idiosyncrasies
because some people don't find it's a
dating at all wow right so there's
probably just some idiosyncrasy there
but most people find it very sedating
which obviously works against the use of
it as an antidepressant right but what
was found is it's actually quite a safe
medicine and again we want it to be
prescribed and there are some risks to
it it's not entirely safe but but by and
large with appropriate prescribing it's
quite a safe medicine that that often is
sedating enough that it can really be
helpful to people for
sleep so
when it doesn't work or if the dose has
to be too high and then it's sedating it
makes sense to shift away from it but
it's a good tool to have or a good arrow
in the quiver right pharmacologically
because it does help a lot of people
with little to no side effect you've got
to get the dosing right and see can the
right dosing for sleep be also
non-sedating enough for that person so
they don't have a hangover from it
essentially the next day
is there any
i suppose this is true with just about
anything but
addiction potential
with trazadone can it be physically
addictive or is it is
more so a psychological risk if any
yeah there could be a psychological risk
is it anything that we're sort of
leaning on so to speak to some degree we
can really habituate to and come to rely
on but that's different than the
mechanisms of physiological addiction
which don't which aren't present in
transit wouldn't apply right what is the
d and d2 stand for in the receptor that
you mentioned with respect to i believe
it was the antipsychotics dopamine
dopamine yeah yeah all right it's fun to
check dopamine is a currency right so
these people say what does dopamine do
it's like saying what does a dollar do
right it depends on where we're spending
it and in these particular circuits
dopamine then becomes a currency of
distress and if there's enough of it a
currency of psychosis so so these
because sometimes people think of
dopamine as pleasure right so why are we
doing anti-dopamine things in these
particular circuits that's not what
dopamine's buying right it's a currency
of distress and we want to play that
down
five man i could talk to you for hours
and hours we've done it before thank you
yeah yeah yeah this is just i find it so
endlessly interesting and what what's
what makes it also so fun to
spend time uh
one of the additional reasons it's so
fun to spend time chatting with you is
that
you are not isolated in in ivory tower
working with hypothetical
cases like people come to you for help
and solutions so
you are a
an active
clinician
who is working with with real patients
you know i have a note here
and i'm definitely going to need you to
to help me elucidate this but
the stress diathesis model
am i saying that correctly
well
stress diathesis which also it's called
a vulnerability stress
diathesis i knew i was going to [ __ ]
that one up those words we like in
medicine because it sounds smart but all
it really means is is a is a genetic
vulnerability which is why that's also
called a vulnerability stress model
which means we all have
genetic vulnerabilities to certain
things right it might be
depression for me and panic attacks for
you or vice versa right that our our
genes give us a predisposition towards
and then the stressors so so that's say
maybe the nature of it right but then
the nurture part is what can bring
a potential problem to the forefront so
you think about a post-trauma syndrome
we're all protected or vulnerable to
different degrees say
at conception based upon genetics now we
don't understand that fully but we know
we have different risk profiles and then
it's the the stress or the the nurture
part of it right what we experience in
life that can determine what comes to
the fore and this is also where the
multiple hit hypothesis of post-trauma
syndromes comes to the fore that it may
be that something really traumatic
happens to a person and they don't have
a post-trauma syndrome then something
else happens then something else happens
and we might think well they're pretty
genetically protected right but but the
stress can take its toll where maybe the
third fourth fifth sixth hit even if it
might be a relatively minor one compared
to those that came before it now create
a full-blown post-trauma syndrome
thank you yeah you're welcome sure
you know we could go in a million
directions outside of your book which
i'm i'm going to
mention again
are there any particular
resources that you might recommend for
people who are interested in in learning
more about
trauma from
credible sources
you know i think nami
which is which is present throughout the
the country and his local branches
throughout the country and ami that that
nami can be
extremely helpful uh we can often find
resources and have links to good people
what does nami stand for
nami stands for the national alliance on
mental illness and nami often has
resources and links to support
mechanisms in the community and i think
can be
very very helpful the book the body
keeps the score by dr van der kolk is
also a very very helpful resource and
anything that helps a person to to find
some inner peace
inside of them something that takes away
from the swirling inside of us that can
happen post-trauma and the swirling from
the social circumstances around us
anything that helps us get away from
what's keeping us in the same loops that
lead us further from truth whether it's
the truth of our own trauma or the truth
of the trauma going on in the society
around us the response to the pandemic
the impact of systemic racism the
erosion of faith in our socioeconomic
model like these these can be seen
through a political lens existential
distress related to
climate change and things like that for
instance right i mean these things can
all be seen through a political lens and
because they get politicized it takes
people away from actually looking at
like what's really going on here how is
it impacting how i'm thinking and
feeling what's the truth of all of this
right anything that takes us away
from from getting lost in the
politicizing of things and more towards
the apprehension of the true existential
nature of these things so there are a
lot of helping resources and things that
we can do to get us into a calmer place
inside
and i know that's a kind of a
non-specific answer but there's so many
routes of of proceeding towards that
that i i want to mention that you know
that too
absolutely
paul conte paul conte dr paul conte
conti.com
pacificpremiergroup.com we will link to
all of these things everything we've
mentioned in the show notes
the new book which i highly highly
recommend everybody pick up take a look
at it get it for people who need it is
trauma the invisible epidemic
subtitle how trauma works and how we can
heal from it
i'm such a fan of yours i don't say that
lightly we've spent real time together
i've seen
the results of of what you do
you are a a in the trenches practitioner
and i'm just so glad that your work
you personally and this book are going
to be
available
to more people so
thank you for
for taking the time thanks so much tim
absolutely means a lot to me thank you
is there anything else you would like to
say or
any request of the audience any
suggestion anything at all that you
would like to
say in
closing comments before we wrap up for
today i think the one thing i would say
is that you know our lives and the world
around us can seem to us to be very
helpless and hopeless at times we can
feel helpless and the world can seem
hopeless and and that's not the case i
mean i cannot describe the number of
people i have
seen worked with who feel that way and
really are at risk when they're feeling
that way and come out to a different
place that if you're feeling that way
that probably means that those blinders
have closed in and closed in and closed
in and there is help for that there
really and truly is and if you're not
getting help the first second third time
keep trying there's help there to be had
and it can make just such
a difference because those narrowed the
narrow blinders represent a risk to us
that comes from trauma and that we can
absolutely do something about and change
perfect place
to ramp up and
so nice to see you paul thank you you
too thank you so much it was fun i knew
it was going to be fun
yeah yeah absolutely yeah this was this
was a really
really enjoyable conversation uh very
dense to everybody listening once again
i will put links to everything we talked
about in the show notes at tim dot blog
slash podcast you can just search conti
c-o-n-t-i
and it'll pop right up
and
until next time be safe
be aware of blinders we all have them
pay attention to your stories
because you are the author not just the
reader of those stories and they craft
your reality
and as paul said uh
you are not alone
this is part of the human condition
and there are
people and tools
and help available and there are things
that work so
thank you for being here paul you're
very welcome thank you for having me and
thanks to everybody for listening
you